dc movies might be about superheroes
striving to make the world a better
place but they're not all sunshine and
daring rescue
a lot of characters good and bad don't
survive we're here to take a look at
their last words before they meet their
maker
superheroes are often created as an
answer to global unrest
rising to solve violent conflicts that
previously seemed insurmountable
general eric ludendorff in 2017's wonder
woman stands in dramatic contrast to
this
he's actually based on one of the
real-life villains of the 20th century
after contributing to significant german
military victories in world war one
ludendorff became a major factor in the
nazi's rise to power
he was a vocal proponent of the myth
which blamed
germany's defeat on homefront sabotage
by multiple
groups most prominently the jewish
population
obviously his demise in wonder woman is
well warranted
he views war as a god that bestows
meaning on men while requiring
sacrifice this leads to what appears to
be a grudging respect for diana
simply for her power alone at the end he
says
as magnificent as you are you are still
no match for me
he turns out to be dead wrong as
dangerous as general ludendorff is to
the world
especially through his collaboration
with dr poison the greatest threat in
wonder woman is
otherworldly ares the greek god of war
has been seeding destruction for a long
time
he implants ideas of war in the minds of
humans but
insists that their natural corruption is
what actually leads to violence
diana in contrast believes that the most
natural quality of humanity
is love as much as the world might
forget this it's the most important
virtue
no matter what terrors pop up as she and
aries duke it out he tries to take
advantage of her grief over losing steve
trevor
diana asserts that she's devoted to her
belief in love
despite the pain of steve's death aries
responds
then i will destroy
you
these words are his last diana redirects
his lightning back at him
just as she redirects grief into love
steve trevor's goodbye and wonder woman
is heartbreaking especially since he's
the person who helps assure diana that
humans have goodness inside them
when diana and steve infiltrated gala
for german high command
she hopes to confront ludendorff who she
believes is aries
she's bewildered then when the general
dies
and the war rages on diana still has a
lot to learn about human evil at this
point but also
about human goodness steve gives her a
lesson in virtue when he makes
the ultimate sacrifice when diana
attempts to stop him
he refuses he originally tells her it
has to be me
it has to be me i can save today
you could save the world he regrets that
they don't have more time
and diana interjects to ask what he's
saying all he has left to tell her
is this i love you one of the surest
signs of goodness is the ability to see
good in others in his last words steve
exhibits this quality
he knows what he has to do because he
knows diana is the only one strong
enough to save the world
in man of steel fiora zod's loyal second
in command
dies on the ship that crashes into the
black zero prison craft
this collision opens a black hole that
sucks feyora and the crew
into the phantom zone feyora actually
doesn't speak in her final scene and her
final words in the film
are a rather pedestrian few zod gives
her command of the ship
and she says they aura
take command yes sir not
long after feyora tries to stop the last
ditch effort to counter
zod's plan the hero of the day winds up
being colonel hardy
as hardy flies kal-el's ship to
metropolis feyora hijacks it he realizes
that the only way to stop zod
is to sacrifice himself in the moments
before their assumed demise
hardy repeats the words she said to him
in an earlier encounter
he echoes her and says a good death
is its own reward going out the way they
do
probably isn't what she meant towards
the end of man of steel zod threatens to
destroy a family of innocents to show
superman how futile his desire to
protect humanity truly
is as zod's laser vision moves closer
and closer to the family
he taunts the man of steel superman
pleads with him to stop
and zod responds
[Music]
with no other choice superman snaps his
neck
when zod dies in his arms superman
breaks down and cries
killing zod doesn't exempt superman from
mourning he mourns the enemy who ravaged
both planets kal-el has called home
the scene is pivotal in superman's
development having first-hand experience
with how it feels to take
a life it's cemented in his mind that he
will never
do so again there are two major deaths
in dawn of justice
but no actual last words to speak about
though he's a huge villain
doomsday doesn't exactly have a final
speech because well
he doesn't really speak but actions
speak louder than words and threatening
to destroy superman and the world as we
know it is a pretty substantial action
so we'll count that as his final words
superman
ends this film in a coffin though
considering that he comes back later his
last words here aren't
actually his last words but part of the
significance of his final words and dawn
of justice
comes from who they're urgently spoken
to this tension
is evident in what he thinks will be his
last words which
are to lois lane this is my world
no clark don't
you are my world immensely powerful
stuff considering that he knows exactly
what it's like to lose your whole world
luckily for this world he comes back
there are quite a few deaths in suicide
squad
which is no surprise based on the
movie's title monster t goes early when
the crime boss
visits the joker's club and makes the
mistake of ogling harley quinn
when the joker calls his girlfriend over
and begins taunting monster t
the gangster quickly realizes that he's
crossed a line
wanting to avoid the joker's jealousy he
says
i don't want no beef but it's too late
the joker abruptly
shoots him in the head slipknot's last
words are a similarly simple tragedy
captain boomerang claims that amanda
waller is only playing mind games with
them and that their heads won't actually
explode if they try to escape
slipknot asks boomerang how do you know
this
mind games or not slipknot gets the
answer to his question
he doesn't survive his escape attempt
finally top
joker henchman johnny frost says some
quintessential superhero flick
last words before their helicopter
explodes
we got a problem he is unfortunately
correct enchantress's last words in
suicide squad reflect her strong
connection to her sibling
and their shared power and past
initially she asks for death
and she's about to have her wish granted
however rick flagg demands that she
first
bring joon moon whose body the witch has
used as a vessel back to the human world
rick doesn't give up hope of saving june
when he threatens to crush enchantress's
heart in his hands if she doesn't bring
june back
enchantress thompson says she's not
coming back i'll crush this do you hear
me
go ahead you don't have the balls
remembering june's wish that he take
down the sorceress
at all costs flag proves enchantress
wrong and
crumples her heart he's delighted when
the act also brings
june back enchantress's last words are
however a defiant final sentiment a
fitting end for a goddess who never
stopped wanting to return to her throne
el diablo is primed to offer the
ultimate sacrifice because he's already
done the emotional work of coming to
terms with his accidental murder of his
family
when enchantress telepathically offers
to fulfill the suicide squad's
deepest desires he alone is able to
power through his longing for his wife
and children
he's fully grieved already so he can let
them go
a powerhouse emotionally physically and
supernaturally el diablo commits to a
final battle to destroy incubus
as the contest progresses and he lures
incubus into the trap set by the squad
he calls out to his team to finish the
job
at this moment he realizes that he has
to go down in order to vanquish incubus
once and for all just before the two get
blown up el diablo utters some pretty
great
last words for his own part incubus
doesn't say much during the final battle
his last lines in the movie come much
earlier
as he seeks to restore power to his
sister
dc pulls at our heartstrings in aquaman
when we see that black manta's origin
story involves a heartbreaking goodbye
between father and son
aquaman confronts jesse kane the father
of the eventual black manta david kane
as he attempts to hijack a submarine at
sea unlike some other heroes aquaman has
fewer qualms about destroying villains
after he defeats jesse and prepares to
leave aquaman
scolds him for setting such a bad
example
kane's retaliatory shot breaches the
hull of the submarine and causes a
torpedo to pin him to the wall
effectively sealing his fate regardless
of the example jesse set for david
it's aquaman's decision to leave him to
die that really turns the tide toward
vengeance in black manta's heart
jesse pulls the pin on a grenade so that
his son will leave his side
and avoid drowning saying hey you need
to live
so you can kill that son
now
thus a quest for revenge is spawned
said savannah's story in 2019 shazam
ends
not in a showdown with a hero but with
his own brother thaddeus
sid's abuses towards his brother are
motivated by grief and resentment
thaddeus had his young boy been selected
by the wizard shazam to become his
champion
but was then rejected due to impurity of
heart confused
and hurt thaddeus has an angry outburst
while in the car with his father and
brother
causing them to crash and his father to
become crippled sid who goes on to rise
at the ranks of their father's company
blames thadius for the tragedy
and tortures him from that day forward
the last words of thadius's tormentor
are representative of his abusive
temperament
when thadius boasting newfound power
shows up to a board of directors meeting
to confront his father
sid snarls don't make me throw you out
of here
that you don't need to make a scene
after this thaad throws sid out the
window instead
in birds of prey huntress racks up a
significant body count
among her kills is victor zaz a serial
killer and
employee of roman cyanus zaz is paranoid
and neurotic working with dinah lance
aka black canary at roman's instruction
but never fully trusting her shortly
before he dies he lets loose on her
after discovering that local thief
cassandra kane has swallowed the coveted
bertinelli diamond
saying that he knew dinah couldn't be
trusted and that roman can only trust
him
dinah tells him he's just being paranoid
yeah mm-hmm prove it to me
rip open her little tummy yeah that's
not gonna happen
now that's the last thing he says before
huntress
shoots him and dinah and harley finish
the job girls gotta stick together
black mask serves as something of a
second joker to harley quinn his
patterns of intimidation and abuse to
her and the women around her nearly
break her
after engaging in a tense exchange with
him as he lurks in the shadows
during which harley realizes that mr
jay's figures are not her protectors but
her tormentors she tries and fails to
shoot black mask hitting a decoy instead
he taunts her insinuating that she
doesn't stand a chance to defeat him but
harley isn't the same harley any longer
she's undergone major changes in the way
she thinks about herself and what she
deserves
harley even tells cassandra that she
made her want to be a less terrible
person
pretty much the opposite of the impacts
the joker or black mask have ever had on
her
roman's reply not very iconic for final
words but a fitting summation of the
condescension harley faces
his final dismissal means nothing to the
two young women however
especially since cassandra has planted a
bomb on him harley kicks the villain off
the bridge
as the grenade detonates watchmen begins
with rorschach discovering a
terrible truth and he eventually dies
doing the same thing
he tries to warn his fellow vigilantes
in the interim but they don't really
take him seriously
still his quest to alert them displays
his doggedness
this is in contrast to those around him
when an old compatriot ponders what
happened to the good old days of working
together
rorschach dismisses him by calling him a
quitter something rorschach
could never do his sense of duty an
obsessive personality
keep him on the streets but they also
alienate him from everyone he's ever
called an ally or
even a friend his final surrender comes
as a sacrifice in service of truth
and his devotion to it after he watches
ozymandias traumatize the world
he realizes the enormity of what's
placed on him
he has information that could bring the
world crumbling down
and just as in the beginning he can't
commit to keeping it quiet
and so he implores dr manhattan to kill
him what are you
waiting for
[Music]
he shouts one more time and dr manhattan
obliges
leaving nothing but a bloody patch in
the snow
though the live-action batman films
sustained plenty of casualties on the
villains side
most of them are minor characters after
all batman's no kill rule is central to
his identity and has deep roots in his
violent origins the joker as a result
rarely dies in any batman related media
batman has reflected before on how he
can't ever kill the joker because he
wants to so badly
he knows that if he gave into that
impulse he might not be able to pull
back
the death of jack nicholson's joker in
1989's batman
is appropriately enough preceded by
these words
sometimes
it's a demise of his own design all
batman does is tether him to a gargoyle
and the joker's attempted escape
leads to his fatal fall batman keeps to
his coat
sort of as we see in the next moment
when he saves himself and vicki vale
from plummeting to the ground
batman has another grappling hook on him
does that
count in violating his rule time
and again batman finds himself dangling
from a deadly height
only for his enemies to meet their end
at the bottom instead
twoface suffers this grisly fate in
batman forever
it's a bit hard to tell if this was an
accident when two-face flips his coin
that batman's suggestion the hero
flusters the villain by tossing a bunch
of decoy coins into the air
not inherently a lethal strike but
considering that two-face was balancing
on a metal beam at the time
what else did bats expect to happen as
two-face prepares to shoot batman and
his crew batman reminds him that he
should let the coin decide
since he's always of two minds about
everything two-face
has an impressive response for him the
emotion's always the enemy of true
justice
thank you you've always been a good
friend some poignant lost words to the
man who
sort of kind of kills him but it's a
pretty perfect line considering that
it's knowing harvey dents so well as a
friend
and foe that allows the dark knight to
best him one last time
bane appears to have every advantage
against batman in the dark knight rises
his goal is to destroy gotham and force
batman to watch
only allowing him the mercy of death
once he's seen everything he loves go up
in flames
but vengeful mass homicide is
complicated
eventually it becomes inconvenient to
keep batman alive
even though the final stages haven't yet
been executed
this change of plan is a small sacrifice
for bane who doesn't seem overwhelmingly
bothered when he tells batman
we both know that i have to kill you now
you all just have to imagine the fire
but
that never happens because he's shot in
the chest by selena kyle operating the
batpod's cannon
the image of gotham burning is a bitter
threat to this film's batman who has
watched his name
burn for eight years to keep gotham
standing
but bats will weather the fires of the
city's hatred forever
if it means that gotham is safe from the
flames this
shrinks is one that bane can never match
and never completely kill
rosal ghoul's death in batman begins
reflects batman's ongoing
internal struggle between good and evil
the villain was once batman's savior and
mentor
without him there would be no batman at
all
and yet he's corrupt and batman has to
make his peace with that
if he can the two adversaries brawl on a
runaway train transporting a microwave
emitter that will be used against gotham
roz holds the upper hand on his foe but
eventually batman takes control
raz still taunts our hero when it looks
like batman is going to kill him
and asks do you finally learn to do what
is necessary
batman replies that he wouldn't take
raw's life but he also
doesn't have to save him in his last
moments roz realizes that batman is
indeed equipped to win
against injustice injustice like him
batman is simply doing what roz taught
him he's devoting himself to an ideal
batman's commitment to compassion is
alien to
the league of shadows is a bit more
let's just say
not compassionate when it comes to well
everything
this devotion makes bruce more than an
ordinary man in a cape
as ross claims at the start of their
throwdown it makes him legendary
though the main villains in batman vs
superman dawn of justice weren't human
there were certainly a couple of earthly
adversaries who made things
difficult for the good guys for part of
the film two of the most
vicious of these african terrorist
general amaza and russian mercenary
anatoly kenyazev were working together
and their last words have a similar ring
to them
though he didn't have as big of a role
in this film kenyasev is the alter ego
of a dc comics super villain known as kg
beast fans are hoping that somehow or
other the character will get another
chance in the dc cinematic universe that
explores the breadth of his presence in
the comics
multiple people have pointed out that
the original character is cybernetically
enhanced
and that perhaps these modifications
could have been a result of the
explosion that
at least as far as batman vs superman
viewers know killed him
perhaps if his last words hadn't been so
threatening
he might have lived i'll kill her
believe me i'll do it in his final
moments the warlord amazon attempts to
put superman in a bind by holding lois
lane hostage
of course superman doesn't need to take
any steps at all when he can fly at
supersonic speeds
he rams amazon through the wall before
he has a chance to fire the shot
while it certainly seems like general
amazon meets his
end at the man of steel's hands director
zack snyder left things ambiguous in a
text posted on reddit which stated
amazon was
quote not dead but not a problem either
either way we won't be hearing from him
again
in a superhero universe dead or alive
status can get
a little confusing but when a character
exits the scene for good
you can usually pick up on the intent
and the old wizard shazam dissolving
into dust after transferring his powers
to billy batson
is as good an indication as any shazam
lives on but the old wizard
is gone plus his last words come in the
form of an extremely quotable speech
give background on the magic and age-old
conflicts at play
and lay the groundwork for billy to
become the hero he is meant to be
after explaining that his brothers and
sisters have all been wiped out
shazam finally convinces the young boy
to speak his name
and become the new champion carry my
name
and with it you carry all my powers
after that billy gets to skip puberty
and become a deep voiced
deified superhero just before the wizard
crumbles into dust he offers
one more nugget of wisdom with your
heart unlock your greatest power
the thrones of our brothers and sisters
await one of the first victims of
ozymandias's scheme to unite the world
by manufacturing a nuclear threat
is a vigilante known as the comedian
with vigilantism outlawed a few former
vigilantes like the comedian
became government agents instead and
when he learned of vasimandius's plans
ozymandias had him killed by this time
though the comedian is beyond
disillusioned with the state of the
world and the relative
powerlessness of any one person to
combat the injustice inherent in it
by the time he meets his end the
comedian had already had his last laugh
long ago seeing life and the power
structures that control everything we do
as a huge joke though he fights his
assailant to the end
there's a dull note of defeat in his
voice when he offers his final words
it's a joke it's all a joke
in the end though he had fought for
justice all his life as a vigilante what
he really wanted for himself was
forgiveness for the injustices
he himself chose to commit along the way
since rorschach discovers him dead
malik's last words on film come
significantly before his actual demise
must have occurred
in a previous meeting between the two
men rorschach confronts malik
a retired super villain at his apartment
demanding to know why malik attended the
funeral of the comedian civilian alter
ego
and how malik knew they were the same
person malik's account details an
encounter with a drunken and unmasked
comedian who invaded malik's bedroom
late at night
malik feared that he was there to kill
him but the comedian just wanted to talk
seeing that rorschach is satisfied
enough with the story molok asks if
things are settled between them
rorschach rummages through one of his
drawers
and finds an illegal prescription malik
begs him not to confiscate it
saying that he's trying any treatment
for his cancer
you know the kind you eventually get
better from
that ain't the kind i got the 2012 final
installment of christopher nolan's
batman trilogy the dark knight rises
finds talia all ghoul carrying on her
father's legacy as one of batman's chief
adversaries though
she doesn't reveal herself as such to
begin with instead she elects to have
bane do the dirty work for her
making it his personal mission to
destroy gotham as
her father wanted while talia
masquerades as bruce's confidante and
lover
but if you want something done right
eventually you really do
have to do it yourself that's why when
batman manages to overpower bane
talia steps in stabbing the caped
crusader from there
it's pretty easy to figure out that she
is not who she said she was but
she helpfully reveals her identity as
razal ghoul's daughter just in case
anyone was confused talia has been
working to finish what her father
started
ever since his death all she cared about
was vengeance for her father's death and
the realization of his destructive goals
and her last words pay tribute to her
life as she remotely floods the reactor
chamber that has stabilized an atomic
bomb
my father's work
is done check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell
so you don't miss a single one